pas tant
jacques guéry philippe bouvard
et quand la barre incroyable fini alors
vous citez souvent cette phrase de
heartbeat cheval qui dit quand un
journaliste interview à un autre
journaliste comme quand on danse avec sa
soeur j'aimerais avoir une sorte alors
là vous dites également et ça c'est pas
de boer valls êtes vous un jour mon
refus de vieillir sera pathétique
oui c'est pas encore aujourd'hui le plus
gros est fait dans ce centre et la flore
et ça va encore les très bonnes minutes
voulais vous féliciter
oui vous avez d'excellentes maquilleuse
a alors vous refusez de raccrocher les
gants fut une nouvelle fois bien de
reconnaître retour sur rtl pour
reprendre les grosses têtes
est-ce que vous avez des nouvelles de
stéphane duhamel c'est lui qui vous a
mis dehors non non non je les croisés
mais dans deux événements parisiens et
là il ya eu un petit ballet bien réglé
c'est là la chorégraphie des gens qui
s'aperçoit mais ils veulent pas se dire
bonjour
chacun est parti d'un coûteux boxe je
n'en veux pas du mal que j'ai pu dire
sur lui voir une telle journée
vous avez un média de spécial là ça va
maintenant c'est réglé harb s'est réglé
tous les gens qui m'avaient poussé
dehors sont allés ailleurs mais je n'en
demandais pas tant
alors après votre retour sur rtl
philippe houzé publié un livre qui
c'était la belle vie
après 70 ans ou vous révéliez qu'un
quart des français de 70 ans font
l'amour trois fois par semaine alors que
la moitié des 60 ans le font deux fois
par mois
oui c'est une statistique on m'a
communiqué je n'ai pas mise en doute
je ne vais pas non plus vérifié à loin
de mon propre comportement ray en fait
ça marche comment tout et je pense que
je vis comme si j'avais 30 ans quand un
quand j'avais 30 ans mais de façon
parfois un peu plus modérées un peu plus
prudente et en travaillant davantage
parce que chemin faisant j'ai laissé
tomber quelques vis donc vous repartez
au combat qui vous voir ce qui est
absolument extraordinaire à l'âge de 73
ans vous devenez directeur général de
france soir en charge du contenu du
marketing de la pub non ça mais je suis
un collaborateur non pas historique de
ce journal mais préhistorique il ya 30
ans aujourd'hui que j'y faisais mon
entrée je suis très attaché à ce titre
très attaché au quotidien qui ne laisse
à ceux qui travaillent ce rythme
pratiquement aucun répit on sort jamais
de l'actualité je me suis dit il ya un
problème pour la presse quotidienne
nationale et d'ailleurs il commence à
atteindre la presse quotidienne
régionale
c'est que l'offre qu'on fait aux
consommateurs d'information ne
correspond plus à leur demande et si
cette offre ne correspond plus à la
demande c'est parce que la presse
quotidienne nationale n'a guère changé
depuis 1945 alors que le panorama
médiatique c est complètement
bouleversée il ya peu de raison en tout
cas beaucoup moins que par le passé que
quelqu'un qui a eu la veille au soir
gratuitement à domicile des informations
un sorte de chez lui le lendemain matin
pour aller les acheter
donc il faut faire autre chose et je
suis partie de ce postulat que qui
demandent qu'à être vérifiée mais dans
ce cas là ce sont les lecteurs comme les
téléspectateurs qui ont toujours le
dernier mot que
la télévision nous avait fait beaucoup
de mal il était en train de nous tuer et
que peut-être si on prenait en compte le
fait télévisuelle el nour et susciterait
alors ça signifie que je vais avoir dans
le journal tous les jours 10 pages
consacrées à la télévision et pas dix
pages à froid avec des avants papier
uniquement des programmes non non avec
du show avec les critiques de la veille
même de la veille au soir
et puis on n'avait pas le choix c'était
la performance ou mourir
moi je préfère la performance alors
c'est très bien mais c'est quand même la
deuxième fois que vous êtes chargé de
sauver france soir la première fois que
vous l'avez sauver c'était entre 87 et
89 tirait la 450 mille emplois
oui oui oui oui et à jouer ça continue à
descendre quand même là vous êtes à 70
mille ha oui oui oui oui et je voudrais
que d'ici les vacances nous nous ayons
repris un niveau plus normal d'ailleurs
on retrouvera pas le million le million
de la taille à huile 1 mais à ce moment
là les médias n'étaient pas ce qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui
en revanche en revanche 120000 rassemble
aujourd'hui une hypothèse plausible
bon vous serez pas obligé de sauver
trois fois c'est ça que je veux dire non
en bane on attendait la dernière chance
je me prends ça parce que c'est vraiment
très très triste de penser que si ça ne
marche pas exactement comme on veut il y
aura plus de france soir pourquoi dans
les taxis chaque fois qu'on rentre il ya
les grosses têtes et bien se sont accrus
que cézanne est comprise comme disent
les publicitaires et les hommes
politiques je crois que les taxis sont
des relais d'opinion 1 et les chauffeurs
de taxi qui sont sensibles à cette bonne
humeur générale
il ya cet irrespect total parce qu'on ne
respecte rien ni personne et on a très
souvent pris françois bayroux comme tête
de turc j'ai fait avant ça elle avant
non non on continue on va être arrêté
tout va bien bon françois bien où la cei
est l'un des ondes et ça parlait alors
qu'il a dû leur vendent depuis longtemps
de son autobus causa vous avez compris
ce truc
ouais françois c'est une des meilleures
idées que j'ai vu c'est dire la qualité
des autres
c'était vraiment le truc le plus sympa
qu'on pouvait imaginer d'aller
rencontrer les gens en bus ça marche ça
marchait très bien en allemagne
ça marchait très bien grande bretagne ça
marchait très bien aux états unis rien
en france et donc les chauffeurs de taxi
nous aiment ils nous écoutent tout le
temps et quand on vous montez dans la
chauffeur de te dans un passé pas moins
que vous trompez démission
vous nous entendez forcément dites moi
non mais sérieux alors maintenant
sérieusement pourquoi pourquoi pas
profiter de votre votre maison sur les
hauteurs de cannes aux ferrari votre
piscine et ça faut quand même que ce
soit terrible chez vous pour vous passer
autant de temps à bosser à votre avis
qu'est ce qu'elle dit colette c'est pas
très sympa point cette espèce de d'après
touring l'eau comme ça j'aurai une
maison sur les hauteurs de calme
jusqu'au boulot aussi tout en haut vous
coûter je vais vous dire je ne travaille
pas je m'amuse ouais j'ai la bonne comme
vous que d'exercer en même temps un
métier bifteck un métier passion et je
me suis habitué à ne rien faire d'autre
que de travailler si je m'arrête de
travailler je suis un homme mort et ça
ferait plaisir à trop de monde
là